Ever wanted to know how professionals
find perfect entry points? Today you'll
get a trading strategy and a
ready-to-use template that reveals where
and when smart money enters positions.
SMC and volume analysis work on any
market and you don't need years of
experience to use it. Let's get straight
to practice. The chart template link is
in the video description. Go to
templates, click settings at the bottom,
and then import. Load the ready-made
template into ATAS and add it to
favorites.
Now you have a footprint chart on your
screen. The main column shows bids and
asks. The smaller one shows delta. Can't
remember what's what? Here's a trick
that always works. BAD, bids asks delta,
left to right. That's the right order.
Now, let's talk about entry conditions.
Our strategy requires that the entry
candle meets four conditions.
First condition, the candle closes as
positive or negative. We have already
covered this in our SMC video series,
but we'll remind you how it works.
Second condition,
delta direction.
It's simple.
A green number indicates buyer
dominance. A red number indicates seller
control. For longs, you need a
significant positive bias like plus
1355.
For shorts, you need a substantial
negative delta like minus 1678.
Third condition, VPOC, this white
rectangle with peak trading volume. For
longs, your candle must close above it.
For shorts, below it. No exceptions.
Fourth condition, absorption. Don't
worry, we won't delve into complex
theory, which you can study in our
training marathons. We'll explain it
simply. Large absorptions appear as
green diamonds at the bottom of candles
or red diamonds at the top. You can also
detect absorptions by looking at the
delta column. For long entries, look for
negative delta values at the bottom,
minus 300 and minus 170. This is where
retail traders were aggressively selling
at market, while smart money was filling
their limit orders. For short entries,
we look for positive delta values at the
top, plus and 85, plus 244, 247, and
others. Here, retail traders are buying
up sell limit orders, while
institutional players are unloading
positions.
And remember, missed even one of the
four conditions, the trade is canceled.
No debates, no exceptions.
And a small bonus, conditions that
improve your chances.
Imbalances.
Green numbers scattered across the
footprint show an explosive uptrend. Red
numbers for shorts show aggressive
selling pressure.
Zeros at extremes.
For longs, a zero at the very bottom is
relevant, like 5x0. For shorts, a zero
at the top.
Feeling overwhelmed? Don't worry. We'll
now analyze live examples.
You'll also learn in which zones to look
for an entry point, and in which to skip
a suitable candle.
Look at this red candle. Most traders
see bearish sentiment, right? But
following SMC principles, we look at
where it closes, far above the 50%
midpoint. Institutional players see this
as a positive candle. Buyers controlled
the situation despite the red color.
They pushed the price up and maintained
their positions.
Now, check this green one. Looks
bullish, but it closed in the lower
half. This is a negative candle. Sellers
dominated, pushing the price down. The
green color is misleading, but the
internal structure reveals the truth.
Don't just look at the color. Draw a
line at 50% between high and low, and
remember which way the candle is
structured.
Closing above 50%,
positive candle, regardless of color.
Closing below 50%
negative candle, even if it's green. The
closing price always tells the truth.
But, here's what's critically important.
Never trade based on this condition
alone.
First, find a zone where price might
react, then use the template to confirm
that institutions are actually
responding. When you see all conditions
at the expected level, it means the big
players are on your side.
So, which zones should we focus on when
trading? Let me show you something
game-changing. If you know how
institutional players capture liquidity,
you know exactly which zone to look for
entry points. See this double bottom?
Most traders think support will hold.
Price tested this level twice and
couldn't break through.
Then they go long. What do we see? A
liquidity trap ready to spring. Don't
immediately trade on a double bottom,
let's observe. Smart money thinks
differently. They don't respect support
levels, they hunt them. When large
players need to enter a long position
with huge volume, where do they go?
Right where retail traders have their
stop losses or are entering shorts.
Below this double bottom lies a gold
mine of liquidity. These patterns repeat
everywhere, double tops, triple bottoms,
daily and weekly highs, extremes of
European or Asian sessions. These are
common and obvious patterns where
liquidity is most predictable.
Watch what happens when price breaks
through this double bottom. This
downward spike isn't a natural price
movement, but an institutional trap.
Smart money triggers every stop loss,
grabs all the liquidity, then instantly
returns price back up. Retail traders
get burned while the big players fill
their positions at perfect prices.
Now, let's switch to 5-minute charts for
precise timing. Find patterns on
15-minute charts, execute on 5-minute
charts. Here's the perfect formula.
Here's our entry candle after the
liquidity sweep. It meets all
conditions.
Positive candle closes well above 50%
regardless of color.
Delta shows plus 251. Buyers dominated.
Closed above VPOC. Buyers broke through
volume.
See the minus 17 in the footprint?
Sellers absorbed. And a bonus, four
green imbalance numbers. Explosive
upward acceleration.
Zero at the bottom, completed auction.
All six conditions aligned. Enter long,
place stop just below the sweep low,
target 2.1.
Beautiful, isn't it?
The key to success, start thinking like
a liquidity hunter. When you see price
approaching obvious levels, think not
only about support and resistance, but
also about stop loss clusters.
When this double top formed, price was
in rotation. As soon as you recognize a
double top, draw a horizontal line,
switch to the 5-minute time frame, and
wait.
This candle swept the liquidity,
triggering stop losses even above the
significant high. Institutional
investors filled their short positions.
Notice the diamonds indicating massive
absorption, as well as the delta values
of plus 347 and minus 320. Extremely
high positive numbers.
Would smart money open long positions in
this situation? Definitely not. Instead,
this green delta indicates liquidity
absorption.
Let's check our trading setup. Negative
candle,
negative delta,
close below POC,
zero at the high,
red imbalances everywhere.
All conditions for a short entry are
met.
Enter short at the close of this candle,
place a stop one tick above the range
high, and ride the distribution phase
with smart money as they push their
newly filled short positions.
This isn't an evil conspiracy by
institutions. It's just business
efficiency. Predictable retail behavior
creates concentrated pools of orders
exactly where they need them.
Another way to trade our setup is to
watch for changes in market structure.
This is your classic compass for finding
entry points. Stick to multi-time frame
analysis. Read structure on 15-minute
charts. Execute on 5-minute to filter
out noise.
Concept is simple.
Uptrends create higher highs and higher
lows. Downtrends create lower highs and
lower lows.
But here's the game changer.
You need to notice when control shifts.
The magical moment, change of character.
When an uptrend drops below a previous
higher low or a downtrend rises above a
previous lower high,
control has just shifted. Most traders
completely miss this and continue
fighting the old direction. Perfect
example here.
A beautiful series of higher lows
confirms the strength of an uptrend.
Then, boom. This candle closes below the
previous low. That's a change of
character. From this moment, stop
hunting for longs and start looking for
shorts.
What happens next? Price retraces to
retest the broken level. Old support
becomes new resistance. This is your
entry zone. Large players use this
pullback to build positions while retail
provides liquidity.
Let's analyze these 5-minute candles one
by one.
This one closes above 50% despite
negative delta. Not our entry.
This one closes negative but has
positive delta. Disqualified.
These two have positive delta. We skip
them.
This one has negative delta and closed
negative, but closed above VPOC.
Mandatory condition failed.
And here it is.
Negative candle, negative delta, closed
below VPOC,
absorption above the level.
This is our short entry.
Stop one tick above and we move with the
new downtrend.
This works both on reversals and
continuations.
After the change of character breaks the
high, switch to the 5-minute and wait
for a pullback. Previous resistance
becomes new support.
The template confirms institutional
absorption during the pullback,
indicating continuation of the move.
Another perfect candle. All six
conditions aligned for a long.
But wait, we got stopped out.
Don't panic. This is liquidity sweep in
action.
Smart money returned to the area,
created more absorptions and extreme
delta. This was necessary to build
strength for the real move.
Move to the sweep candle. All conditions
are met, plus confirmed liquidity sweep.
The initial shakeout just loaded more
spring into the explosive rise.
Still sounds complicated? Then watch our
video smart money, market structure and
liquidity.
Your next clue for entry is fair value
gaps, which act literally as price
magnets. Once you start noticing them,
they'll work in your favor.
Look at this 15-minute chart. Here price
creates aggressive sequences of three
candles. The first candle ends here, the
third candle starts at the top, and the
middle candle shot upward.
The market moved so fast that it skipped
price levels, leaving this gap behind.
This gap acts as a future magnet for
price. Why? Because large players create
gaps through urgent entries or exits.
Few transactions occurred in this area,
leaving unfilled orders and unsatisfied
demand.
Let's switch to the 5-minute chart to
see the magic. When price returns to
test these if vigils, look for entry
conditions right at the boundaries. The
larger the gap, the higher your chances.
And the best setup is when a fair value
gap aligns with the structural levels we
discussed earlier. Let's find the
perfect entry point.
See this green candle? Looks like a
signal, right? But it closed below its
midpoint. This is actually a negative
candle despite its color.
But this next candle fulfilled all six
conditions. And with it, we could move
long following smart money.
And finally, you can easily use this
strategy with order blocks. They
precisely reveal where big money entered
positions.
These aren't single levels. They're
entire zones where institutions
systematically close old positions and
enter new ones in the opposite
direction.
Why are these extensive zones? Because
large players cannot dump huge positions
through single transactions without
shifting price against their interests.
They methodically return to necessary
price levels, creating clear footprints.
Here's the system for hunting order
blocks. Use only 15-minute charts or
higher to eliminate noise and false
signals. Look for them at swing
extremes, swing highs for bearish
blocks, swing lows for bullish blocks.
Watch how price gradually decreases into
this swing low formation. For bullish
order blocks, find the final negative
candle in this area.
It's either the candle with the lowest
low or the one before it. This candle
represents pure seller dominance before
the institutional reversal.
But you need confirmation. Look for
structural confirmation through change
of character or break of structure after
the order block forms. Here's our break
of structure, confirming the shift from
bearish to bullish control.
The second confirmation is a fair value
gap immediately following the order
block and extending beyond its
boundaries. This FVG shows institutional
urgency and strength creating momentum.
Both confirmations present, then you
found the perfect order block. Now
switch to the 5-minute chart and
patiently wait for the final retest.
When price returns to test the block,
apply the conditions for finding the
candle. Notice how price deviates from
this zone during retesting.
Here's our entry candle because all
mandatory conditions and one bonus
condition are fulfilled.
But we got stopped out. That's liquidity
sweep in action. The institutions
decided to return to the order block,
dip deeper, and shake out retail longs
like us. We discussed this concept at
the beginning, so it's just an
additional reason to look for a new
entry point. Obviously, smart money is
working.
This green candle may look tempting, but
remember, color lies. Using Fibonacci,
we see it closes below 50% of its
height. This is actually a negative
candle.
The next candle gives us another chance
to enter the market. Five conditions
aligned, and even without the sixth,
it's obvious that institutions captured
additional liquidity for the move.
Second tests often reveal final
absorption before explosive movement.
After liquidity sweep, you'll also get
stronger order blocks, which is why we
recommend using this strategy fully,
accounting for all market situations.
Look at this stretched candle, clear
evidence of liquidity sweep with
absorptions in the shadow. It satisfies
all order block criteria.
We mark this zone with a rectangle on
the 15-minute chart and wait patiently.
Institutional reactions don't follow
intraday trading rules. They unfold over
days or weeks waiting for optimal
conditions.
After more than a week of waiting, boom.
Notice how the VPOC on this candle
perfectly aligns with our order block
boundary. This isn't coincidence. It's
recognition of the exact price level
where large players positions remain
active.
The next candle becomes our setup for
entry.
Patience when trading with delayed order
blocks really pays off. When smart money
is finally ready to act, the market's
reaction often exceeds retail investors
expectations as accumulated
institutional interest has created truly
strong momentum.
That's it. Time to put the setup to work
and follow the institutional wave. And
don't forget to download the template in
the description. It's your advantage
even if you're going to partially
supplement your strategy with it.
Hit subscribe if this opened your eyes
to how institutions really move markets
and check out our other videos on
advanced analysis.